[Musique]
et pour en débattre à nous sommes avec
antoinette laurin vice président
entendez républicaine france bonsoir
antoinette laura merci d'être à vos
côtés pour débattre théo lobry
animateurs du groupe bernie sanders
france bonsoir théo lobry merci d'être
avec nous vous aussi à leur première
question a tout d'abord sur ce processus
électoral qui suit son cours a toujours
aux états unis les grands électeurs sont
appelés aux urnes
à leur tour ils se réunissent et par mg
en état par état toute la journée
aujourd'hui donc pour officialiser la
victoire de jo byden ils vont le
désigner comme prévu aucun doute
là-dessus théo lobry oui a priori aucun
doute déjà plusieurs états ont des
signes et enfin les grands électeurs ont
déjà parlé dans plusieurs états
notamment la pennsylvanie ou encore la
géorgie et si bien joe biden qui a
remporté les grands électeurs de ces
états donc a priori il n'y aura aucune
surprise
ce qui est tout à fait normal alors sur
les réseaux sociaux et tout
particulièrement twitter donald trump
lui digère toujours aussi mal sa défaite
il continue de dénoncer les fraudes
toujours sans savoir fournir de vraies
preuves un finalement regarder ses
derniers tweets c'était hier les états
clés qui ont trouvé une fraude massive
ce qui est le cas pour tous ne peuvent
pas certifié légalement ces votes comme
complet est correct sans commettre un
crime sévèrement punissable tout le
monde sait que les morts les mineurs les
immigrés clandestins
les fausses signatures les prisonniers
et bien d'autres ont voté illégalement
en outre les défaillances de la machine
un autre mot pour fraude
la récolte des bulletins de vote les
électeurs non résidents les faux
bulletins de vote
le bourrage des urnes les votes pour
l'argent la brutalité des observateurs
du scrutin républicain et parfois même
plus de votes que les votants a pris
place à détroit philadelphie
milwaukee atlanta pittsburgh et ailleurs
dans tous les états clés il y à beaucoup
plus de voix que nécessaire pour gagner
l'état et l'élection elle même
par conséquent les votes ne peuvent être
certifié
cette élection est contestée
antoinette laurent ces accusations de
fraude on parle depuis le début en
quasiment depuis le 3 novembre donal
trump ça fait vraiment est courant chez
les militants républicains
beaucoup y croire finalement dans votre
camp
bien sûr mes yeux je veux aussi raconté
l'attention de ceux qui sont en ce qu'on
appelle les rails no reaper de cunene on
dit en fait dans les législatures de
chaque état on voit une complicité des
républicains qui ont choisi le voir
contre le président tente est en fait
président 30 pour représente nouveau
parti il ya des rumeurs de ce qui
s'appelle ce nouveau parti mais tout
simplement il faut vraiment que votre
chat les spectateurs comprendre que le
le mainstream media de médias qu on voit
cnn m a semblé si ni abc abc il ya une
complicité
franchement très forte contre président
on avoue aujourd'hui que si elle n était
attaquée en justice par le suppliant de
ces chrétiens des fentes cache pas tel
aujourd'hui pour 50 millions de dollars
c'est à dire qu' il s'agit d'une grande
façon de diffamation contre les gens qui
soutient entrants et il faut aussi
prendre attiré l'attention du
téléspectateur de de la fête que les
démocrates il y demande de violentes
contre les supporteurs le train est par
exemple avec landry au cardio portel
comment s'appelle américains se retirent
johnson elles étaient 1 a publié une
vidéo sur facebook on appelons tous les
supporters de trop et elle a menacé avec
la violence d'une personne assez
importante elle
et corriger quand même mais il faut
pardonnez moi parce que là vous faites
allusion à plusieurs choses si j'ai bien
compris il ya le côté que vous dénoncez
partisans des médias américains et après
voilà d'autres fêtes de violence entre
les supporters parce que cette campagne
a été a été rude
théo lobry est ce que justement vous
l'admettrez vous parce que pour avoir eu
la chance de couvrir des élections aux
états unis on va pas se mentir il ne s'
en démentant pas eux mêmes c'est vrai
que les médias américains étaient pro by
day excepté évidemment fox news comme
chacun sait mais c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
une campagne menée par les médias
américains en faveur en tout cas contre
donald trump ça vous l'admettrez du côté
des démocrates
oui je crois que toute façon pour ce qui
est de 6 m nns nbc et c'est
effectivement sans démocratie ce sont
des médias pardon de la côte est des
états unis plutôt démocrate mais on va
dire la ligne centriste c'est à dire que
démocrate version joe biden ou
républicain version mitt romney
admettons donc ça on peut tout à fait
l'admettre après il faut il faut pas
oublier que fox news a eu une importance
toute particulière durant ces quatre
dernières années
qu'aujourd'hui les réseaux sociaux sont
absolument saturé par la parole des
ultra conservateurs et des trump heist
par exemple et en plus de ça le fait est
que cnn et tous les médias qu'on
pourrait qualifier de démocrates ont
participé aussi à faire advenir donald
trump à la présidence des etats unis
puisque en permanence en fonction de ses
phrases qui etc
il parle de lui alors ils sont coincés
parce qu'ils sont obligés de parler de
lui mais ça lui fait aussi de la pub
c'est de l'argent qui n'est pas dépensé
dans la campagne pour des spots
télévision puisqu'il donald trump et la
télé tous les soirs donc oui c'est
quelque chose qu'on peut admettre en
effet mais je ne suis pas sûr
aujourd'hui que
cnn où ces médias qu'on a cité juste
avant et une influence énorme les
etats-unis sont à ces fractures et les
républicains ne regarde pas cnn les
démocrates ne regarde pas foxes
antoinette laurent ont parlé de ces faux
d'intro d'un que dénonce donald trump et
qui font écho chez les militants vous
parliez de ces médias américains mais
enfin tout de même il y a tout
simplement les recours judiciaires et
pour l'instant ça n'a rien donné pour le
président trump à ce qu'il en a encore
quelques-uns oussaillès est trop tard
d'abord je souhaite à passer les pointes
des moteurs de mon collègue qui en fait
partie des morts continue
il a démontré avec resplendissent et les
autres joueurs disent qu'ils sont fait
partie prise il ya du deux poids deux
mesures
en fait en ce moment vers nous met et
verts - jamais reconnue et nous met tous
considérés comme pertinents dans le
journalisme sans dryades et ce qui est
intéressant aujourd'hui pour moi c'est
la sortie du thé puis sur les bases de
données de janeiro calligrammes tony g
vous connaissez comme moi ta -cg
rigouste en national monsieur qu'est
vous nationaliste ce qui est intéressant
c'est tous les partis communistes
supporter d'un autre pays occidentaux il
ya une règle 95 millions des partis
communistes enregistrées dans des bases
de données qu'on a découverte et ils ont
promis au parti communiste chinois de
garder le secret du parti de être fidèle
de travailler dur et de 7,1 pour le
communisme est en fait on trouve dans
cette des coûts découvert aujourd'hui
que pfizer
astrazeneca ceux qui produisent des
vaccins il ya 123 fidèle à ce parti
communiste alors un petit moment il faut
vraiment poser des questions surtout que
les médias nous dit parce que en fait
[Musique]
c'est pas du tout ce qu'on comprend deux
dans des réalités
en tout cas à propos de ce vaccin
antoinette laurent donald trump se
défend lui-même il affirmé hier sur
foxnews d'ailleurs que les états unis
auraient mis cinq ans à développer un
vaccin contre le corps un avis au rugby
rue s'il n'avait pas été président théo
lobry est-ce que vous lui concédé au
moins cela à donald trump c'est vrai
qu'il avait été très critiquée en
annonçant en septembre qu'un vaccin les
survenir certainement avant novembre et
finalement ça a été le cas quel est
aujourd'hui votre réaction
alors dans un premier temps je voulais
simplement réagir à ce que ce qu'a dit
la personne qui débat avec moi ce soir
on est encore dans une dans une
démonstration un exemple de toute cette
sphère conspirationnistes complotistes
qui tient les partisans donald trump
enfin du moins une partie des partisans
de donald trump je l'aimé pas tous dans
ce même sac et vous voyez bien voir
enfin j'espère que les téléspectateurs
se rendre compte à quel point c'est tiré
par les cheveux
le parti communiste chinois qui aurait
plus ou moins une ingérence auprès de
pfizer qui une entreprise privée
américaine qui est sous l'autorité du de
des autorités sanitaires américaines
enfin cette marche complètement sur la
tête et le pire dans tout ça c'est
qu'effectivement comme vous l'avez
rappelé c'est sous la présidence de
donald trump que ce vaccin est apparu et
a été diffusé dans le monde
c'est une prouesse on espère qu'avec le
temps les résultats seront positifs pour
ce vaccin qu'il n'y aura pas de souci
et si là où on peut reconnaître à donald
trump mais c'est plutôt aux états unis
de façon générale un point positif c'est
l'argent qui a investi par les
américains dans la recherche et c'est
bien aussi un petit problème qu'on a
nous en europe et particulièrement en
france
où on voit effectivement tous les
chercheurs qui partent aux états unis
parce que les entreprises ont plus
d'argent les autorités les autorités
soutiennent bien plus la recherche en
france
donc est ce que c'est un point positif
pour donald trump en tout cas ça aurait
été fait pendant son mandat donc
effectivement on peut lui on peut lui
donner le crédit d'avoir soutenu soutenu
cette recherche par le biais de millions
et 2 milliards de dollars faudrait qu'on
termine par à part ces chiffres un + 18%
entre les deux élections donald trump
est passé de 62 à 74 millions de voix en
quatre ans il a donc renforcé sa base
n'est ce pas un peu dangereux tout de
même pour joe biden ce genre de chiffres
à antoinette lorrain vous vous espérez
que votre poule ans représentent en 2024
est-ce qu'il a un boulevard avec ces
chiffres au il en fera un autre jour
selon vous ce sera le mot de la fin
non je crois que 2024 c'est maintenant
ou jamais en fait on dans le compte de
l'âge de président 30 et au monde compte
de l'âge de président mbaye dème en fait
tous les deux ils sont assez à la lignée
de pouvoir présider un pays comme les
etats-unis dans notre pays surtout en
chine tout bon état de santé mentale et
physique du dr dean et démontre des
signes de déclin cognitif mentale et
physique mais par rapport de mai source
au niveau de vote populaire dans notre
pays il a gagné 4 20 et 4 21 millions de
votes par 74 en fait c'est dommage parce
que votre monsieur triaud l'a à clermont
ferrand
en fait vous savez que par des nuls à la
volée pour les vaux de cernay qui était
tout haut
le candidat des développeurs et parce
que pour les téléspectateurs parce que
c'est vrai que tout voilà on millions de
votes
c'est par rapport de senécal et des
world les avocats qui sont entrain de
d'embauché les scientifiques
or indiqué étudier les bases de données
des votes dans ce système de dominion
est en fait c'est tout maintenant que
jamais il est important de restaurer
notre système électoral et de données de
sécurité et de vraiment éliminer tous
deux possibilités de deux de tricher par
rapport aux plantes étrangers on peut
dire que en fait les chinois a donné
millions d'euros
on est en train de s'éloigner en tout
cas c'était pour le mot de la fin je
vous demande et voilà si vous pensiez
que donne être un palais être vous
espériez en tout cas qu'il se représente
en 2024 vous qu'on sait que c'est fini
je suis désolé on est à la fin de cette
ce débat effectivement et je ne cache
pas que c'est un petit peu compliqué
parce que ce sont les délégations qu'on
ne peut pas vérifier bien évidemment ici
sur ce plateau
voilà donc vous comprendrez que c'est un
petit peu compliqué effectivement on a
entendu en tout cas votre message on
nous a laissés déroulé tout ça mais
c'est vrai que ce sont des allégations
qu'on a du mal à vérifier n'y fit
donnez-moi est président et dubaï dont
ce n'est pas encore sûr il faut encore
attendre jusqu'au 20 janvier même si le
6 janvier
la constitution américaine donne jusqu'à
22 janvier pour déterminer qui est la
fusion est doux et je pense que cette
bataille il ya 80 fonds américain
millions d'américains qui sont vraiment
en colère de cette fraude grassi dans
notre système électoral
on verra des conséquences mais pendant
ce temps il faut pas laisser l'espoir
d'accord très bien très bientôt car
chacun a exprimé son point de vue merci
antoinette laura merci également à théo
lobry d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france